shaming is kind of like the dirty bomb
that you just throw across the entire
mating Market in an attempt to raise the
supposed price of have you done much
research about shaming it tends to be
predicted by the particular threat of
the woman that you are shaming my
research has found that women are more
likely to share negative reputational
information particularly about women's
sexual history when the other woman is
attractive provocatively dressed or if
she flirts with their romantic partner
so it's more tailored to the particular
mating threat that each woman poses
however I've seen other data find that
women more strongly oppose female
promiscuity when they have more male
sons and so I think that is one
ecological factor is like when does
paternity certainty matter they've done
some work finding that when women in the
environment depend more on men's
provisioning and that's when you're
going to see more clamping down on
female promiscuity